hi john sources tell us police shot and  killed a suspect i can tell you there's  a heavy police presence at this scene no  officers were hurt according to the  metro police department you can see the  crime scene tape is there and then again  a heavy police presence  this is a shopping center where i see an  albertsons again this is along sloan or  near charleston this is in the very  early stages of the investigation you  can see the metro police mobile command  over there again a heavy police presence  police have asked us to stay back we've  moved again you can see the crime scene  tape here again sources tell us police  shot and killed a suspect we don't know  the circumstances just yet but we do  know no officers were hurt reporting  live vanessa murphy live local now